THE WORLD.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
GRIFF.
GRIFF: JACQUI FOR MORE ON THE
CONTINUING CRISIS AT THE BORDER
WE’LL BRAY IN FORMER ICE
DIRECTOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, TOM HOLMAN.
AND WE HEARD FROM THE REPORT
FROM BILL, AND THE KEY WORD WHO
IS COMING IN?
HE SAID SRI LANKA.
I WANT TO ASK YOU IN THE WAKE
OF THE SITUATION IN THE CRISIS
IN AFGHANISTAN AND THE BORDER.
DO YOU SEE A TIE TO THE
VULNERABILITIES OF WHO IS
COMING INTO OUR BORDER?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, I’VE BEEN SAYING, GRIFF,
FOR TWO YEARS THAT THIS BORDER,
WHEN IT’S VULNERABLE, IT’S JUST
NOT VULNERABLE DO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, IT’S ILLEGAL TO
THREATS, PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS
BECAUSE THEY’RE RELEASING COVID
CASES, BUT I’VE SAID FROM DAY
ONE, IT’S A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
BORDER PATROL ARRESTED 17
NATIONALS FROM AFGHANISTAN THIS
YEAR.
IF YOU LOOK AT SPECIAL
INTERESTS, THOSE ON TERROR
WATCH LISTS THEY’VELINE
ARRESTED FIVE.
THERE ARE 300,000 GOT-AWAYS.
TERRORISTS DON’T WANT TO GET
CAUGHT.
THEY’RE PART OF THE 300,000 WHO
GOT AWAY.
AND THAT’S HOW THE FENTANYL AND
THE BAD GUYS GO THROUGH.
IF THEY ARRESTED FIVE, HOW MANY
DIDN’T THEY ARREST?
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT WILL ADMIT
THEY’VE ARRESTED 15 KNOWN
TERRORISTS IN THE LAST DECADE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY’LL ADMIT TO.
BUT THE REPORT IS 100, IN
PANAMA, HSI ALONG WITH PANAMA
SPECIAL AGENTS EN ROUTE TO THE
UNITED STATES IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND LUCKILY WE CAUGHT
THEM IN PANAMA FROM THERE.
THIS IS EXTREME ON THE SOUTH
BORDER.
50% OF THE BORDER PATROL OFF
THE LINE PROCESSING ALIENS,
WE’VE NEVER BEEN MORE
VULNERABLE TO TERRORISTS
ENTERING THIS COUNTRY IN MY
YEAR.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE
HAVE’ GOT TO SECURE THIS
BORDER, IT’S AN EXTREME
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE AT THIS
TIME.
GRIFF: LET ME DRAW ON THAT.
BECAUSE THE OUTGOING BORDER
PATROL CHIEF, RODNEY SCOTT, IN
THE MESSAGE TO HIS FAREWELL TO
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS, HE
VIEWS THIS NOT JUST AS A CRISIS
AT THE BORDER, BUT IN HIS WORDS
A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS AND
SOME COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
HIT THE TERROR WATCH LIST, BUT
NOW WE HAVE THE CVP SAYING IF
THEIR BOARD, A SMALL NUMBER OF
AFGHAN EVACUEES FLAGGED FOR
CONCERNS AT BASES AROUND THE
WORLD AND WE HAVE CVP AGENCIES
LIKE YOURSELF WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE DOING THE VETTING.
DO YOU SEE THAT THREAT HIGHLY
INCREASE NOW BECAUSE OF THE
MASS EVACUATE IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE CVP PERSONNEL
DON’T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
ARE.
THERE’S NO U.S. EMBASSY THERE,
THERE’S NO CONSUL OFFICE THERE.
AND HOW ARE WE VERIFYING
PASSPORTS ARE GENUINE?
HOW DO YOU VERIFY THE IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS WHO THESE PEOPLE
REALLY ARE.
I KNOW FOR A FACT TALKING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT DULLES
AIRPORT HERE IN D.C., THAT A
LOT OF THESE AFGHANS GETTING
OFF THE PLANES THEY HAVE ZERO
IDENTIFICATION.
NOT ONE PIECE OF PIPE WHO THEY
ARE.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
HOW DO YOU VET THEM WHEN YOU
DON’T HAVE ANY DOCUMENTS FROM
THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT OR FROM
THE AMERICAN CONSULATE.
SOMETHING ELSE AND--
>> TOM, I HATE TO--
I HATE TO CUT YOU OFF.
WE’VE GOT TO GO DOWN TO NEW